[Applause]
Bill McKibben Jim Dean Governor Hassan
Senator Shaheen thank you very much for
your kind remarks
and let me Begin by thanking the 13
million Americans
who voted for me during the Democratic
primaries
and thank you New Hampshire for giving
us our first great victory
and a very special thanks
to the people of the state of Vermont
whose support for so many years as the
mayor as a congressman as a senator and
as a presidential candidate have
sustained me and Jane and our entire
family Vermont thank you
let me also thank the hundreds of
thousands of volunteers
throughout this country and every state
in the Union who work so hard on our
campaign
and the millions of contributors who
showed the world that we could run a
successful national campaign based on
small individual contributions
[Applause]
two and a half million of them
together we have begun a political
revolution
[Music]
to transform America and that Revolution
continues
together we will continue to fight for a
government which represents all of us
and not just the one percent
a government based on the principles of
economic social racial and environmental
justice
I am proud of the campaign we ran here
in New Hampshire and across the country
our campaign won the primaries and
caucuses in 22 States
and when the roll call at the Democratic
National Convention is announced it will
show that we won almost
1900 delegates
[Applause]
far more than almost anyone thought we
could win
but it is not enough to win the
nomination
secretary Clinton goes into the
convention with
389 more pledged delegates than we have
and a lot more super delegates
[Applause]
[Music]
secretary Clinton has won the Democratic
nominating process
foreign
and I congratulate her for that
she will be the Democratic nominee for
president
and I intend to do everything I can to
make certain she will be the next
president of the United States
thank you
[Music]
I have come here today not to talk about
the past but to focus on the future
that future will be shaped more by what
happens on November 8th in voting booths
across our nation than by any other
event in the world
I have come here to make it as clear as
possible as to why I am endorsing
Hillary Clinton
and why she must become our next
president
during the last year I have had the
extraordinary opportunity an
extraordinary opportunity to speak to
more than
1.4 million Americans at rallies in
almost every state in our country
I was also able to meet with many
thousands of other people at smaller
gatherings
and the profound lesson that I have
learned is that this campaign is not
really about Hillary Clinton or Donald
Trump or Bernie Sanders or any other
candidate who sought the presidency
this campaign is about the needs of the
American people and addressing
[Applause]
and addressing the very serious crises
that we face and there is no doubt in my
mind that as we head into November
Hillary Clinton is Far and Away the best
candidate to do that
it is very easy to forget and
Republicans want us to forget where we
were seven and a half years ago when
President Obama came into office
[Applause]
as a result of the greed recklessness
and illegal behavior on Wall Street our
economy was in the worst economic
downturn since the Great Depression
some 800
000 people a month were losing their
jobs we were running up a
record-breaking deficit
and the world's Financial system was on
the verge of collapse
we have come a long way in the last
seven and a half years and I thank
President Obama and
I thank President Obama and Vice
President Biden for their leadership in
pulling us out of that terrible
recession
[Applause]
but I think we can all agree that much
much more needs to be done
too many Americans are still being left
out left behind and ignored in the
richest country in the history of the
world there is too much poverty there is
too much despair
this election is about the single mother
I saw in Nevada who with tears and arise
told me that she was scared to death of
the future because she and her daughter
were not making it on the ten dollars
and 45 cents an hour she was earning
this election is about that woman and
the millions of other workers in this
country who are falling further and
further behind as they try to survive on
totally inadequate wages
Hillary Clinton understands that we must
fix an economy in America that is rigged
and that sends almost all of the new
wealth and income to the top one percent
[Applause]
Hillary Clinton understands that if
someone in America Works 40 hours a week
that person should not be living in
poverty
[Applause]
she believes
we all believe that we must raise the
minimum wage to a living wage
and further she wants to create millions
of new jobs by rebuilding our crumbling
infrastructure
[Applause]
our roads our bridges our water systems
our Wastewater plants
but her opponent Donald Trump well he
has a very different View
he believes that states should have the
right to lower the minimum wage or even
abolish the concept of the minimum wage
if Donald Trump is elected we will see
no increase in the federal minimum wage
of
7.25 cents an hour a starvation wage
this election is about which candidate
will nominate Supreme Court Justices who
Opera
who will nominate Supreme Court Justices
who are prepared to overturn the
disastrous citizens united decision
[Applause]
a decision which is allowing
billionaires to buy elections and is
undermining our democracy
this election is about who will appoint
new justices on the Supreme Court who
will defend a woman's right to choose
[Applause]
who will defend the rights of the LGBT
community
who will defend workers rights the needs
of minorities and immigrants and the
government's ability to protect our
environments
[Applause]
if anyone out there thinks that this
election is not important take a moment
to think about the Supreme Court
Justices that Donald Trump will nominate
and what that means to civil liberties
equal rights and the future of our
country
this campaign is about moving the United
States toward Universal Health Care
[Applause]
and reducing the number of people in our
country who are uninsured or
underinsured
Hillary Clinton wants to see that all
Americans have the right to choose a
public option in their health care
Exchange
which will lower the cost of health care
for Millions
she also believed
that anyone 55 years or older should be
able to opt in to Medicare
and she wants to see Millions more
Americans gain access to Primary Health
Care Dental Care Mental Health
counseling and low-cost prescription
drugs
through a major and dramatic expansion
of Community Health centers throughout
this country
[Applause]
Hillary is committed to seeing thousands
of young doctors nurses psychologists
dentists and other medical professionals
practice in underserved areas as we
follow through
on President Obama's idea of tripling
funding for the National Health Service
Corps
in New Hampshire
in Vermont and across this country
we have a major epidemic of opiate and
heroin addiction
people are dying every day from
overdoses
Hillary Clinton understands that if we
are serious about addressing this crisis
we need major changes in the way we
deliver mental health treatment
throughout this country
[Applause]
and that is what expanding community
health centers will do and that is what
getting medical personnel into the areas
we need them most will do
and what is Donald Trump's position on
Health Care well no surprise there same
old same old Republican contempt for
Working Families
he wants to abolish the Affordable Care
Act throw 20
throw 20 million people off of the
health insurance they currently have and
cut Medicaid for low-income Americans
the last thing we need
America is a president who doesn't care
about whether millions of Americans will
lose access to the Health Care coverage
they desperately need
we need more people with access to
Quality Health Care not fewer
Hillary Clinton also understands that
millions of our seniors disabled
veterans and others are struggling with
the outrageously High Cost of
prescription drugs
she and I are in agreement that Medicare
must negotiate drug prices with the
pharmaceutical industry
and that we must expand the use of
generic medicine
drug companies should not be making
billions in profit while one out of five
Americans are unable to afford the
medicine they need
the greed of the drug companies must end
this election is about the grotesque
level of income and wealth inequality
that currently exists
the worst it has been in our country
since 1928.
Hillary Clinton knows that something is
fundamentally wrong
when the very rich become richer while
many others are working longer hours for
lower wages
she knows that it is absurd that
middle-class Americans are paying an
effective tax rate higher than hedge
fund millionaires
[Applause]
and that there are corporations in this
country that make billions of dollars a
year in profit yet because of the
loopholes that their lobbyists created
in a given year they do not pay a nickel
in federal taxes that is wrong
while Hillary Clinton supports making
our tax code fairer and more Progressive
Donald Trump wants to give hundreds of
billions of dollars in tax breaks to the
very wealthiest people in this country
his Reckless economic policies will not
only exacerbate income and wealth
inequality they will increase our
national debt by trillions of dollars
this election is about the thousands of
young people I have met
throughout this country who have left
College deeply in debt
the many others who cannot afford to go
to college and the need in this country
to have the best educated Workforce in a
highly competitive global economy
[Applause]
Hillary Clinton believes
that we must substantially lower student
debt and that we must make public
colleges and universities to wishing
free for the middle class and Working
Families of this country
this is a major initiative
that will revolutionize higher education
in this country and improve the lives of
so many of our people think of what it
will mean think of this
when every child in this country
regardless of the income of his or her
family knows that if they study hard if
they take School seriously yes they will
be able to get a college education and
leave school without that
this election
is about climate change the greatest
environmental crisis facing our planet
and the need to leave this world
in a way that is healthy and habitable
for our children and future Generations
[Applause]
Hillary Clinton is listening to the
scientists who tell us that if we do not
act boldly in the very near future there
will be more drought more floods more
acidification of the oceans more rising
sea levels she understands that we must
work with countries around the world in
Transforming Our Energy System away
from fossil fuel and and
away from fossil fuels and into Energy
Efficiency and sustainable energy
[Applause]
and that when we do that we can create a
whole lot of good paying jobs
well Donald Trump
like most Republicans
sadly and tragically is choosing to
reject science
something no presidential candidate
should ever do
he believes that climate change is a
hoax in fact he wants to expand the use
of fossil fuels
that would be a disaster for our country
and for the entire planet
this election is about the leadership we
need to pass comprehensive immigration
reform and repair a broken criminal
justice system
it's about making sure that young people
in this country are in good schools or
at good jobs not in jail cells
secretary Clinton understands that we do
not need to have more people in jail
than any other country on Earth at an
expense of 80 billion dollars a year
and these stressful times for Our
Country this election must be about
bringing our people together not
dividing us up
thank you
while Donald Trump is busy insulting
Mexicans and Muslims and women and
African-Americans and our veterans
Hillary Clinton understands that our
diversity is one of our greatest
strengths
yes we become stronger when black and
white Latino Asian-American Native
American all of us Stand Together
yes we become stronger when men and
women young and old gay and straight
native born and immigrant fight to rid
this country of all forms of bigotry
[Applause]
it is no secret that Hillary Clinton and
I disagree on a number of issues that is
what this campaign has been about that
is what democracy is about
but I am happy to tell you that at the
Democratic platform committee which
ended Sunday night in Orlando there was
a significant coming together between
the two campaigns and we produced
[Music]
we produce by far the most Progressive
platform in the history of the
Democratic Party
our job now is to see that platform
implemented by a democratically
controlled Senate
a democratically controlled house
and a Hillary Clinton presidency
and I intend to be in every corner of
this country to make certain that
happens
I have known Hillary Clinton for 25
years
we were a bit younger then
I remember her as a great first lady who
broke precedent in terms of the role
that a first lady was supposed to play
[Applause]
and as she helped lead the fight to
Universal Health Care
[Music]
I served with her in the U.S Senate and
know her as a fierce advocate for the
rights of our children
and I know her and all of you know her
is one of the most intelligent people
that we have ever met
[Applause]
Hillary Clinton will make an outstanding
president and I am proud to stand with
her today thank you all very much
thank you
hello New Hampshire
it is so great
it is so great to be here with so many
friends old and new
[Applause]
thank you
thank you so much I
I have to say it is such a great
privilege
to be here with Senator Sanders
being here with them in New Hampshire I
can't help but reflect
how much more enjoyable this election is
going to be now that we are on the same
side
because you know what we are stronger
together
[Applause]
and I want to give a special thanks to
someone who
has been with Senator Sanders every step
of the way not just throughout this
campaign but over the years
his wonderful wife Jane Sanders
and also I've had the pleasure of
meeting his son Levy Sanders thank you
[Music]
I also appreciate greatly
having
the opportunity for all of us to hear
from the speakers beforehand
Governor Maggie Hassan the next senator
from the state of New Hampshire
[Applause]
Senator Gene Shaheen who is doing a
tremendous job for you
and we are delighted to have heard from
and have with us Bill McKibben and Jim
Dean
[Applause]
over these last few weeks Bernie and I
have worked together on plans to put
College Within Reach for more people
and to ensure that everyone in America
has access to quality affordable health
care and
now with your help we are joining forces
to defeat Donald Trump win in new
November
and yes together build a future we can
all believe in
just as Bernie said over the years I've
gotten to know him as a colleague and a
friend
his reputation for passionate advocacy
hasn't always made him the most popular
person in Washington
but you know what that's generally a
sign you're doing something right
and throughout this campaign
Senator Sanders has brought people off
the sidelines and into the political
process he has energized and inspired a
generation of young people who care
deeply about our country and are
building a movement that is bigger than
one candidate or one campaign so thank
you thank you Bernie for your
endorsement but more than that
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you for your lifetime of fighting
Injustice I am proud to be fighting
alongside you because my friends
this is a time for all of us to stand
together these have been difficult days
for America
taking yes they do and taking on
taking on the systemic racism that
plagues our country and rebuilding The
Frayed bonds of trust and respect
between law enforcement and the
communities they serve will require
contributions from all of us and we have
to begin by starting to listen to each
other and more than that
we then have to come together
to do something that will help us fix
these problems and heal these wounds we
have to reform our broken criminal
justice system take back our democracy
from the wealthy special interests and
make our economy work for everyone not
just those at the top
[Applause]
and you know what
we have to do all these things at the
same time
that's why throughout this campaign
we've been calling for eliminating
racial profiling and disparities in
sentencing ending the era of mass
incarceration dismantling the school to
prison pipeline providing more
employment opportunities for formally
incarcerated people
in addition to that
I am proposing two new steps that get
law enforcement the support they need
while also stopping the tragedy the
tragedy of black men and women and black
children being killed in police
incidents
[Applause]
thank you
first
first let spring law enforcement and the
communities they Swear to protect and
serve together to develop national
guidelines on the use of force by police
officers
and second
let's provide better training on
implicit bias
[Applause]
that remains a problem even in our best
police departments but it also remains a
problem across Society
and I'm asking for all of us to really
search our hearts and Minds to make sure
we don't
we don't have those implicit biases
let's learn from police departments like
Dallas that had made strong progress and
apply their lessons Nationwide because
everyone in every Community benefits
when there is respect for the law and
when everyone is respected by the law
[Applause]
remember
when gunfire broke out in Dallas
the peaceful protesters and the crowds
that had gathered to support them
ran to safety while the police officers
who just minutes before had been talking
with and taking pictures with and
protecting the protesters the police
officers ran the other way they ran into
the gunfire
[Applause]
that's the kind of courage and
dedication our police and First
Responders show every single day so yes
let's take real meaningful action to end
the epidemic of gun violence in America
[Applause]
from Sandy Hook to Orlando to Dallas and
so many other places
these tragedies tear at our soul
and so do the incidents that don't even
dominate the headlines
just this past Sunday
a young man Seth Rich who worked for the
Democratic National Committee to expand
voting rights
was shot and killed in his neighborhood
in Washington
he was just 27 years old
surely we can agree that weapons of war
have no place on the streets of America
our police and First Responders should
never have to face
a Madman
a racist
a person filled with hatred
with an assault weapon we owe it to
every officer who puts his or her life
on the line to protect us so let's
protect them and we can't stop there
this is part of a broader challenge
across our country inequality is too
high wages are too low and it is just
too hard to get ahead for too many
Americans
[Applause]
we need an economy that works for
everyone not just those at the top not
just the Millionaires and billionaires
but everybody and to do that we need to
go big and we need to go bold this isn't
a time for half measures
so we are setting five ambitious goals
for starters in my first hundred days as
President we will make the biggest
investment in new good paying jobs since
World War II
more jobs here in New Hampshire and
across our country especially in places
that have been left out and left behind
in communities of color in Coal country
Indian Country everywhere where a person
deserves the same shot at the American
dream as anybody else in our country
thank you
and when I say good paying jobs I mean
it as Bernie said Donald Trump thinks
wages are too high he actually stood on
a debate stage and said so
he does want to get rid of the federal
minimum wage altogether
well both Senator Sanders and I believe
anyone who is willing to work hard
should be able to find a job that pays
well enough to support a family and
Bernie is Right
7.25 cents an hour is a starvation wage
so sorry Donald if you're watching
we're not cutting the minimum wage we're
raising the minimum wage
and we're going to create millions of
good jobs by making America the clean
energy superpower of the 21st Century
as Bernie reminds us so powerfully we
owe it to Future generations to work
together to combat climate change and
we're going to do it we've got the
intelligence we've got the Innovation
we're going to roll up our sleeves and
demonstrate to the world what America is
made of we're going to have that clean
energy economy and we're going to make
it work for everybody
[Applause]
and make no mistake we will defend
American jobs and American workers by
saying no to the assaults on the right
to organize and bargain collectively
and we're going to say no to attacks on
working families and no to bad trade
deals and unfair Trade Practices
including the trans-pacific partnership
yeah
second we're going to make college debt
free for all and help millions of people
struggling with existing student debts
save thousands of dollars here in New
Hampshire you know
students are carrying one of the highest
debt loads in the country
I've heard from young people who can't
start a business move out of their
parents home or even get married because
of all the student debt holding them
back so with your help we're going to
make it so future students won't have to
borrow a dime to attend public colleges
or universities
thanks to the new proposal Senator
Sanders and I worked on together for
families making less than 125 thousand
dollars a year we will eliminate tuition
at those schools altogether
[Applause]
and we will do more to help students
cover all the costs of getting an
education including books supplies and
living expenses
because in the words of a student I met
here in New Hampshire paying for college
shouldn't be the hardest thing about
going to college
third we're going to rewrite the rules
and crack down on companies that ship
jobs and profits overseas
[Applause]
let's reward the companies that share
profits with their employees instead
and we will defend and strengthen the
tough reforms President Obama put in
place on the financial industry not let
Donald Trump tear them up because we do
we do need to make sure Wall Street can
never wreck Main Street again
number four
we're going to make sure Wall Street
corporations and the super rich pay
their fair share of taxes
[Applause]
when people say the game is rigged the
best evidence is our tax code it is
riddled with scams loopholes and special
breaks it is wrong that some
millionaires do pay a lower tax rate
than their secretaries and we're going
to stop it now compare
compare what Senator Sanders and I
intend to do with Donald Trump's plan
his tax plan would make our current
system even worse
independent analysts say he would add 30
trillion dollars to the national debt
in order to give a massive gift to the
wealthiest Americans Wall Street money
managers and our largest corporations
but after all what else should we expect
from someone who calls himself the king
of debt
now we have been pointing out we've been
pointing out the problems with his tax
plan for months and I think Donald is
starting to feel the pressure
in fact even as we speak
he's apparently bringing in the biggest
names and trickle-downs supply-side
economics
to help him figure out what to do now
these are the same advisors who brought
us 30 years of a disastrous Republican
philosophy that gave the huge breaks to
those at the top
now you don't have to be a psychic to
know what's going to happen next
they're going to come back with another
plan with maybe some bells and whistles
Bernie that tries to disguise the fact
that they still are slashing taxes for
the wealthy large corporations and
Donald Trump himself
and they'll try to use voodoo economics
to tell us all the ways it will actually
help the economy
but they're not fooling anybody at least
I hope they're not
just like his current plan which he
calls inspiring tremendous and amazing
you know he uses a lot of adjectives to
avoid telling you any specifics
[Applause]
here's what we know for sure
whatever he comes out with decks is
going to give huge tax cuts to the
corporations and the rich at the expense
of the middle class
now there's that old saying
you've heard it
I used to hear it a lot in Arkansas
you can put lipstick on a pig but it's
still a pig
and I gotta tell you the first time that
the Republicans pulled the voodoo
economics
you know they fooled us
shame on them
but if they come back with the same
argument and people fall for it shame on
us
but I will promise you this Senator
Sanders and I will spare no effort to
make sure the people of America know
that once again Trump and his cronies
are trying to pull the wool over our
eyes and come back with the same failed
policies that hurt us before we're not
going to let them get away with it again
and finally
our fifth goal is we're going to step up
and respond to the way American families
actually live and work in the 21st
century our families and our workplaces
have changed so isn't it time for our
policies to change too
let's expand Social Security to match
today's realities not cut or privatize
it
let's join the rest of the developed
world and offer paid family leave
and finally let's guarantee equal pay
for women once and for all
now
[Applause]
I I can just Envision the tweets Donald
is
putting together
and you know Donald Trump can accuse me
of playing the woman card all he wants
if fighting for equal pay and Paid
Family Leave is playing the woman card
then Dale me in
and I'll tell you these aren't just my
fights these are Bernie's fights these
are America's fights
and I feel with all my being
these are fights we have to wage and win
together
[Applause]
[Music]
as Bernie and his supporters have argued
so eloquently we won't get anywhere
unless we overhaul our campaign Finance
system
[Applause]
past time to end the Stranglehold of
wealthy special interests in Washington
and get back to government of the People
by the people and for the people
that's why as president from my very
first days I will make campaign Finance
reform a top priority we will do
everything we can to overturn citizens
united
and we will require everybody Democrats
Republicans Independents whoever to
disclose all of their donors and while
we're at it we are going to create a
small donor matching system to make it
easy for more Americans to be elected at
every level of government
[Applause]
because just like just like Bernie I
have met so many impressive people here
in New Hampshire and across America with
great ideas for our country I want to
see you run for office and win and
here's another radical idea let's make
it easier to vote not harder
[Applause]
let's fight back against attacks on
voting rights across the country attacks
that disproportionately affect
low-income voters people of color
students the elderly and women that
means
we need to restore the Voting Rights Act
and then keep going
all Americans should be automatically
registered to vote on their 18th
birthday
every state should have at least 20 days
of in-person voting and no one in
America should ever have to wait more
than 30 minutes to cast their ballot
so Senator Sanders and I will be working
to get unaccountable money out of
politics and the voices of everyday
Americans back in because as Bernie has
said this isn't a progressive issue it's
not a conservative issue it's an
American issue
and let me close with this
to everyone here and everyone across the
country who poured your heart and soul
into Senator Sanders campaign
thank you
I was proud of the campaign we ran it
was a campaign about issues not insults
and our country desperately needs your
voices and involvement and so does this
campaign and so does the Democratic
party because you know what we need to
take back the Senate and take back the
house and make sure we have Democratic
Governors and Democratic state
legislators
let's open the doors
to everyone who shares our Progressive
values this is one of the most important
elections in our lifetimes so I'm asking
you to stand with us and then I'm asking
you to keep working in the weeks months
and yes years ahead you will always have
a seat at the table when I am in the
White House
[Applause]
as Bernie will tell you talk is cheap we
need to keep fighting to make sure
everything we've stood for is real in
the lives of people across America this
amazing country of ours
is worthy of our best efforts
this election let's send a clear message
in America we don't tear each other down
we lift each other up we build Bridges
not walls we put common interest ahead
of self-interest we stand together
because we're stronger together
[Applause]
so I need your help
please join this campaign make it your
own you can take out your phone right
now and text join
j-o-i-n-47246 or go to
hillaryclinton.com
we accept 20.27 donations too you know
[Applause]
I can't tell you how grateful I am
to be standing here with Senator Sanders
because I think both of us realize that
each of our campaigns
together
represent the best of Who We Are
and now it is time for us to take that
message to the rest of the country
I am fully aware that the other side
will do everything possible to distort
to disinform and we can't let that
happen
we have to be standing up and fighting
for the America that we know we can
create together I am confident and
optimistic about our future particularly
when it comes to young people I think
America's best years are still ahead of
us so join with us let's make this
happen together and win the election
thank you very much
thank you
[Music]